monsieur gaudin bonsoir à vous je viens
d'annoncer que votre ancienne
circonscription monsieur gaudin passera
aux mains des libéraux
une de celles que vous perdez un
atlantique
le jeu vous c'est très honnête quand on
regarde ces chefs la sexta très mauvais
départ pour le npd et pour les
conservateurs mes parents de jeunes pdc
il reste encore plusieurs boîtes de
votre art est dévoilé je sais que vous
disais qu'elle est sa vocation libéraux
moi je vais encore avoir confiance que
les gens de qualibat tous les sports
tomber un jeune peut aider mais vous
savez en politique on ne sait jamais ce
qui peut arriver quand on parle de vague
à soir je regardais sur la baie des
chaleurs
je voyais pas de tampon qui dînent avec
des points là où les libéraux mais
monsieur commune en même temps monsieur
cormier n'a qu'a dit l'un d'eux on l'a
élu pour les libéraux là on n'y est pas
je sais en avant sont les îles où la vie
du bon donc comment vous décrire comment
vous décoder ce message des électeurs à
ce que les gens vraiment qu'ils
voulaient du changement se sont
agglutinés sont les libéraux voulaient
du changement veut dire qu'auparavant
quand parlement et du changement avec
stephen harper il pouvait la voir avec
le npd
messi qui avons choisi d'y aller avec
les libéraux ça veut dire qu'ils veulent
aller sur côté du pouvoir
ça a été la campagne de serge cormier
qui a tout le long de sa campagne disait
de faux la barque est sur le bord du
pouvoir est probablement ce que lebron
acadie bathurst a choisi mais donc votre
chef
vas tu ranges a même réussi à faire
passer l'idée d'en tête du monde dans
l'atlantique qu'il incarnait le pouvoir
lui aussi la colère ça si on regarde les
résultats de ce sport sous sa triste
parce que 150 ans avec les bleus gris
rouge qui les gens à continuer avec de
la même manière dit qu'un jour ça va
arriver c'est ce que jack layton voulait
qu y arriver mais ça tout à l'air sais
pas ce qui va arriver et vous décourager
vous avez le droit dame ce gadin êtes
vous décourager un peu non je suis
découragé je suis découragé par ce que
j'ai envie d'y aller pour un exemple et
hier qu'il ya des gens qui disaient
qu'ils voulaient réussir
hors du pouvoir mais tu fais rien sur le
bord du pouvoir contre nos nouveaux
produits qu'on a les libéraux sur le
bord du pouvoir qui enlèvent des
infirmières dans les hôpitaux qui
enlèvent des professeurs dans les écoles
qui courent partout on parie sur le bord
du pouvoir qui fait des coupures
alors vous chose de ces aigris ce que la
population encore choisi d'aller avec
les vieux partis
je pars et de le chambrer sadek n'ont
pas eu assez de toutes ces coupures là
puis démontré que les partis politiques
en fait toutes ces années là aussi vont
toujours d'iga les biens donnés dans nos
régions qui si on regarde dans les
régions qu'on a vu c'est et des coupures
comme le 57 médiocre on va aller à
l'assurance emploi
mais le le peuple décide et il faut
respecter ça mais ce gardien on voit des
images en direct de votre chef qui
regarde en famille les résultats
électoraux
c'est toujours difficile quand on voit
que les résultats sont pas au rendez
vous je ne veux pas là vous remettre le
fer dans la plaie mais quand même une
dernière question at-il fait selon vous
la meilleure campagne qui pouvaient ou
bien ça répète meilleur manger dire
écoutez si klm bd pour un exemple je
vous donne un exemple ci aurait dit
qu'il voulait amener le pays 30
milliards dans le rouge
je suis certain qu'il y ait le peuple
aurait dit encore lady qui veut dépenser
saddler que si tout permis pour les
libéraux qu'habré soit de même on va se
mettre à fuir les camps hippocrate en
fait si tous n'en soit rien à faire on
va voir comment ce que le peuple va
réagir d'une semaine mais que tout
recommence à ce procès se doit d'un jour
merci nous avons parlé en direct de
maisonnettes puis voilà vous êtes vous
avez dit ce que vous aviez à dire c'est
très clair merci beaucoup à bientôt un
monsieur gaudin merci bien bonne soirée
à tous